おばけえびを育ててから
19日...
約20日間経ったんですけど
おばけえびは
無事でーす
無事ですよ
バリバリ無事です
元気です
ほどよく（ホントよく元気？）元気でございます
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
というわけで”おばけえび”を飼ってから19日が経ちました
約20日間です
なんか、本には
20日間までにちゃんとした大人になりますって
書いてあったので
もうね、あの結構やばいべ
結構皆さん元気に育ってると思います
てかめっちゃ元気だな
いやホントすごいんすよ
あの、毎日ちまちま見てて
ホントすっげぇデカくなったなって思いますよ
静岡にいるときは絶対動画撮ってるんで
ちょっとね途切れ途切れにはなると思うんですけども
おばけえびの成長の記録見てみましょう
どうぞ！
はい、2日目です
1日目はU-FES名古屋でいませんでした
やっと産れたっぽいですよ皆さん、見えますか？
ほらほらほらほら
見えますかこれ？
結構いるな
結構います結構います
うーん、あんまりまだ可愛くはないな
はいというわけで、これからこの子達を育てていきたいと思いまーす
はい、多分3日目です
どうでしょうか
多分なんか1日経っただけで結構大きくなってる気もしないこともしません
わーーでも多いな
そこそこいるな
4日目です
あー瀬戸さんの動画だ
ちゃんと生きてます
すげーなんか動きが
動きがホント速くなってるな～
すげーな、だいぶ動きが速くなったね
今日も餌あげます
はい、5日目　え、見えねーけど
5日
えーとですね、だいぶ大きくなったね
わかんないけどかなりね最初と比べると確実に成長しております
ちゃんと皆元気です
今日はこの後ちょっと東京に行ってくるので
しばらくお別れだね
ではでは
6日ぐらいでございます
見えますかね
ほら皆すげー元気だな、この子とか
皆ちゃんと元気に生きています
かなり大きくなってきましたね
活発です
8日
8日間でこれだけ大きくなりました
どんな形かっていうのが大体わかるようになってきたと思います
あっ
水槽が傷ついてる
この子たちは何を考えているのかな？
暇だろうなこんな水槽で
10日目でございます
10日目です
かなり実体化してきたね
もう形がわかる
どんな形か分かる
え、めっちゃ大きくなったなー
だいぶ、おばけえびっぽい感じになってきたと思われます
すげー
可愛いな
遠くから見るとわかると思うんですけど
数が全然減ってないです
無事皆元気に生きております
すげー
はいというわけで、13日目です
肉眼でも見れるしね
まだまだ成長するらしいんでね
見ていきましょう
はいというわけで、14日目です
なんか皆さん大きくなって活発度が減りましたね
なんか堂々と泳ぐようになりました
相変わらず数は多いですね
あーでもやっぱ元気だな
うん、だいぶ大きくなってきた
やばいのがいる一人（匹）
どうしたんだあんた
な、な、な、な、なになに
ど、どどう、どうした
心配になるぐらい尻尾が長いですね
15日目でございます
デカい！
もうめちゃくちゃデカくなっちゃった
もう水槽にいても全然どこにいるかわかるくらいの大きさで
かなり見た目がねはっきりしてきたと思います
あんな小さい小粒だったのが今こんなに大きくなっちゃって
うーんちょっと少なくなった気がするなー
餌を（も）ちゃんとあげてるし、部屋の温度もそんな寒くしてないので
問題ないと思うんですけど
少しだけ　あっそーでもねーわ
意外といたけど、ちょっと減った気がします
はい、16日目です
もう体がちゃんとある
すげー元気そして
体がヒラヒラしてるね
なんかね数がすごい減ったんですけどー
今、7,8匹くらいになってしまいました
皆元気にゆっくり泳いでます
普通に可愛いよね
普通にすごくない？
？：あんなちっちゃいのから産れるんですね
はじめ：やばいよね
デケー
めちゃくちゃデカいです
はいというわけで、いかがだったでしょうか
もうホントね目に見えないくらい小さい卵から
もう目で見えるくらい可愛いエビちゃんに成長してくれました
癒されました
ホント癒された
なんか見るたび見るたびすごい動き速かったです最初
でも日が経ってくごとにね
ちょっとのんびりさんになってきて
体がずっしりしてきて、こうちゃんと
ヒラヒラして泳ぐようになってね
いやーほんと良かったです
これ本当はね夏休みに育てるやつなんすよ本当は。
夏休みから秋にかけてって言ってたんで
僕がやってる期間がちょっとずれてて
ひょっとしたらなんか全滅とかするのかなって不安だったんですけども
ちゃんとね元気に育ってくれてて僕はすごい嬉しいです
でも最初めちゃくちゃウジャウジャいたんですけど
やっぱり数がどんどん減っちゃてて
なんなんだろうな　やっぱ環境とかもあんのかな
寿命もあるのかな？
20日間くらいで成長しきるって書いてあったんで
そろそろひょっとしたら、歳なのかもしれません
大人のおばけえびまで成長させれてよかったです
まじで癒されますからね
パッと見クラゲなんだよねクラゲ
もう普通にね目でも見えるくらいなんすよねサイズ的には
よく大きくなったよこんなに
はいというわけで、おばけえび育ててみたんですけども
良かったです
癒されました
一人で話しかけてた自分がアホみたいです
でも、それくらい愛着持って育てれたので
すごい楽しかったでございます
なんかね上手くいけば卵を産むって話もしてたんで
この子達がねこの先、歳を取って寿命が来ちゃって死んじゃってもね
ひょっとしたら卵があるかもしれないんで
まあなんかあったらサブチャンとかに出してみようかと思ってます
まあとりあえず今、大人になって楽しい人生を送ってくれればいいなと思ってます
僕の中学校の先生が言ってたんですけども
なんで皆さん生きてると思いますか？
人生なんてモンはね
思い出作りですよ
死んだら多分”無”の世界なんで何もないんで
生きてる間にどれだけ思い出を作って
楽しい人生が送れたか
まるで自分が楽しいと思うかどうかっていうね
思い出を作ることが
大切なんだって中学校の先生が言ってました
皆さんも
僕も
おばけえびの皆さんも
いつかはどうせ死ぬんで
生きてる間になるべく沢山幸せな思い出作ってください
人生は思い出作りです
何言ってんだ
何言ってんだ俺
いやーなんかね生き物見てたらそういうこと思ったんで
な？残りの人生も楽しめよ
じゃあな！